you know who'd be great to have in this
video is dan cyber from that cyber
channel
he covers a lot of great five nights at
freddy's stuff i know
what am i doing here you disappoint me
by not being damned on a daily basis now
walking i'm like hey dan cyber
i'm editing we're gonna watch the day
from a channel that was recommended our
way
super horror bro make sure to check out
this guy's channel especially if you
like this video
original video link in the description
box finesse
scariest animations and here's why top
scary five nights at
freddy's we cover a scary video probably
like once a week for the last couple
months so subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
we
got a new scary reaction up or if
there's something else that pops up in
your feed from us that's like hey
i like that too that's how notifications
work
um react to it then we'll talk about it
let's do it
[Music]
five nights at freddy's is a long
running series of horror games
in which the player is stalked by
various animatronics
haunted by the spirits of the dead some
of these animatronics have rather morbid
backstories
but all of them are highly creepy in
today's video we take a look at the
scariest animatronics from the fanaf
series taking into account appearance
scare tactics
and backstory to figure out which are
the creepiest of all time
and why
[Music]
many of you may share a phobia of creepy
looking dolls
and clowns definitely circus baby plays
harley quinn
both of these to make for a hair-raising
design
her mouth is open wide with lots of
small human-like
teeth while her eyes are big and bright
baby's mid-section contains a claw which
was supposed to hold
ice cream cones but the animatronic was
originally designed
however there is a haunting backstory to
this claw
circus baby used it to grab a little
girl often speculated to be the daughter
of its creator
circus baby is also scary due to just
how tall she is
however despite how creepy she looks
this particular animator
doesn't actually jumpscare the player
unless we count her scrap version from
finasteride
which is maybe slightly creepier anyway
yeah oh boy
this game is pretty there's always
something a little creepy about humanoid
looking robots
ballora is the most human looking
animatronic and certainly
can be found with her little helpers oh
god
[Music]
and nard an art is surely the most
why do little kids love this game and
its face is covered by a clown-like mask
because this is
cute as this mask is it is far less
scary than what lies beneath it
the masculine is truly the stuff of
nightmares
being silently stalked by enerd during
the security
is a genuinely unsettling experience as
it edges ever closer with a dead look
in its eyes for many this often comes to
a close
with a heart-stopping jump scare
[Music]
and anything that hides in a closet at
night ready to pounce at any
moment is definitely something to fear
however there really is something far
more terrifying
about the purity of the original foxy
and his jumps
boxing foxy first appeared in the
original five nights at freddy's as a
character who would peek out from behind
the curtains show the pirate code
before edging to the corner of the frame
and eventually charging full pelt
over to the player before launching at
them with a blurred
screech oh it runs one of the five
key animatronics believed to be holding
the decaying corpses of william afton's
victims
foxy is also believed to be responsible
for the bite of 87.
this was an accident involving a person
who was bitten by an animatronic and
lost their frontal lobe in the process
in the year
1987. so yeah there's a sinister story
behind
foxy which goes beyond his creepy
appearance
and jump scare so we bit someone's
head like the front of their head
the original bonnie had one of the most
terrifying jump scares of any
animatronic from the
he series would try to forcibly cram any
humans spotted at the pizzeria after
hours
into one of the spare suits with little
care for how they would fit in there
even the developer scott corphan
commented on how he had nightmares about
bonnie
while programming the game and regards
him as one of the most frightening
characters
so nightmare bonnie essentially a
nightmarish looking version of this
already unsettling animatronic
is something else entirely his presence
in the full final game is scarier
not only because of his more gruesome
look but also because of how aggressive
he
is relentlessly coming out of a player
and making it very difficult
for us to avoid him
[Music]
phantom puppet sounds promising puppets
are scary in general but the puppets in
fenath are designed
to look scary from the off and so we get
this creation
phantom puppet is a charred version of
the puppet from five nights at freddy's
this original incarnation was already
something to fear
a tall lanky design that evokes that of
slenderman
with a creepy toothless clown face
the phantom version has a burnt black
body and piercing white eyes
which stare right through our soul what
makes phantom puppets so
scary to experience is the way he will
sneak up on the player in the security
office and
send himself just inches in front of
their face
a weird dial-up noise similar to that of
a fax machine
then emits from the puppet as it stares
right through us
how do you how do you survive that
mango has a very disturbing jump scare
noise that will shake most people pretty
badly
but as well as this she just looks i've
never gotten a good look at
any of these creatures before it was so
deserving
redesigned it was my first time like
really like slowing down and looking at
stuff
and ended up pulling her to pieces on a
regular basis
which resulted in the staff naming her
mangle and leaving her as a pull apart
and put back together attraction for the
kids to mess around with
imagine living in existence where every
day you were taken apart and then stuck
back
together as well as this sad story
and petrifying jump scare the appearance
of mango
is just downright creepy her mutilated
endoskeleton
like at is
disturbing what if sid from toy story
grew up to be
horrifying featuring a decaying version
of the original bonnie soup design
this creepy rabbit animatronic has a
very dark
and mysterious backstory that is sure to
make you feel
a little unnerved you see william acton
the creator of these suits and the evil
man responsible for the murder of five
children
ended up hiding from the spirits of his
victims in this very suit
before the springlock malfunctioned and
snapped almost on him
impaling afton inside the suit and
fusing his body within
the cruel and tortured spirit of this
man now
haunts springtrap as he hunts in fact we
can even catch
glimpses of afton's mummified corpse
within springfield
on occasion this is both a terrifying
and
gory animal
[Music]
let's get straight to the point here
nightmare looking at
there you can probably tell why he ranks
so highly on this rundown of enough
scariest animals sure
visually he is one of the most
terrifying creations simply because he
was designed
to resemble a nightmarish version of
everybody's favorite bear
freddy his suit is actually transparent
meaning that nightmare blends into the
darkness almost perfectly
and this makes him very hard to spot
until he gets very close to us
while his jump scare lacks any kind of
animation it still remains quite
horrifying
the tension feels palpable as we flash
our lights down the hallways
never knowing if nightmare will appear
just inches from our faces
gonna conserve that flashlight
as we come to the final place on this
list we also find the animatronic that
starts ah
freddy fazbear freddie isn't the
scariest looking
his jump scare isn't the worst and his
backstory has been bested by other
creations with darker tales to tell
however freddie is the most consistently
creepy when looking at his character as
a whole
from the wave the power cuts out and
eerie children's music begins to play
before he finally attacks us
the creepy humming we hear through the
halls as an unseen freddy begins to
prowl
i haven't played this game in years oh
my god
sometimes glitch out the security tablet
and that threatening look he shoots us
from time to time
freddie is the ultimate and original
animatronic for evoking fear
in players around the world with his
creation the landscape of
indie horror games was forever changed
and a terrifying legend was born
laying the groundwork for many games and
even scarier animatronics to come after
but nothing quite beats the original
right yeah
and that's it for today's video please
remember to give it a like please do
enjoy watching and maybe drop a comment
too
as well as subscribing to the channel
and turning on notifications
so you never miss an upload this channel
specializes in variety horror content
including creepypasta readings horror
gaming facts and theories
and general interest pop culture horror
[Music]
we got reactions and other reactions to
other
stuff and reviews and when movies exist
yeah reviews
occasional sketch i think we did it
movie variety channel
that's great let's talk about it yeah
first time checking out this guy's
channel and
i thought you did a great job uh this is
a wonderfully
wonderfully edited video i mean i bet
the comments are
a bunch of why didn't you include this
person why not this person
you forgot this yeah not that it just
didn't make the lives for the most part
though i still thought that this
actually gave a really great insight and
i thought the editing on it was
wonderful
and the narrative got me so fascinated
with it because
i'm so out of the loop with five nights
at freddy
like my girlfriend works with children
and she said that
so many kids still play this game it's
awesome
now and i was like wait a minute kids
play this cave
like little kids play this game they get
the merch
they play the game back when hot topics
were still a thing you could go and they
had
islands of freddie merch and it's weird
watching this because i didn't realize
the amount of
lore and characters that are seen built
into
five nights at freddy's i thought it was
just like a gimmick
game that's really taken off and then
like reddit threads
really expanded on the lore and stuff i
didn't realize that there was all this
character lore built into it and the
wide variety
like this is actually really eye-opening
video for me in a lot of ways it had me
going halfway through
my mind was checking out a bit because i
was thinking why have they tried making
like a hard
pg-13 horror movie out of five nights at
freddy's
you can do that with five nights at
freddy's oh totally
like it doesn't have to be gory things
gotta be chilling you gotta be
terrifying we
almost get an r rating for how scary it
is some of them would have to be cgi'd
but you could bring a lot of these with
actual animatronics to life
and make them look just as disturbing as
possible
and you know a lot of time you can get
like some main character who gets
trapped in a place like this and is
encountering all of them it could be
pg-13 it doesn't have to be rated r
so you could get the kids in the theater
still and the adults
this it would be a perfect video game
movie well if i'm not mistaken i believe
they announced this ages and ages and
ages ago and it kind of fell into
obscurity but i believe blumhouse
is still developing the movie with the
original creator so we may get
the first ever first person surveillance
security
evil you know animatronics movie and
this game a lot of it scares beyond its
aesthetic and appearances as
demonstrated in this video
a lot of the scares are based off of
jump scares oh yeah
so it's the perfect plum house movie it
is
so much of the game is just you sitting
there trying to conserve your flashlight
and not shine it in the scariest place
yeah if you just went back to that even
that insidious vibe but just transposed
it into a chuck e cheese
scenario i think it would be perfect
yeah i mean the thing
that is so funny about this to me is
like the game in and of itself
kind of embodies what it's about because
this guy started out making games that
were supposed to be like educational and
even i think religious too
oh really and people were like dude your
animations are kind of creepy
and so he leaned into that and made five
nights at freddy's
fascinating yeah and just to see the
breadth
the growth yeah of just the amount of
different characters and the lore and
how twisted this has all got i think
that there is a certain amount of this
that has been
taken and run with by the fan base but
then the creator was smart enough
to really embrace that because you've
got the sister location to five nights
at freddy's and yeah you have all these
characters and there's this really
horrific lore about all these yeah dead
children embodying the animatronics
that's what i mean you got
you got a lot of like urban legend myth
you could infuse in here to give some
pathos to some of the villainous
characters in five nights at freddy's
yeah it would it be hard to just get a
couple of humans who you care about
yeah put them in there like mark
wahlberg yeah
i think those dolls are alive i'm gonna
go check it out okay
or uh you know flashlights not working
get like kevin james
i was so unaware of the amount of
variety there are two
this is a really eye-opening video yeah
it made me want to go and check out what
the most recent iteration of five nights
is it's crazy how unsettling this is
just from like looking at it ah good job
super [ __ ] bro
definitely liking this video guys make
sure to subscribe to super
horror bros channel got so much content
up on here
top comment says freddie isn't humming
it's foxy i thought everyone knew that
already
whoa totally disgraced well
all the other 11 minutes and 40 seconds
are nothing now they mean nothing
nothing because you got one thing kind
of wrong
better luck next time good luck
superhero bro
unsub nah i'm just kidding buddy
subscribe to him and subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell
hey last but not least
erica tuesday take it away because john
said she's the best one to shout out for
this video erica
i mean erica single-handedly introduced
me to the everything i know about five
nights at freddy's pretty much i've
learned from erica
because she is a super fan of five
nights at freddy's and if there's anyone
i know who's gonna be there
first in line on opening night for that
movie
it's gonna be erica in fact erica is so
dedicated
to fnaf that she has just recently
acquired her own
actual chuck e cheese animatronic and i
believe she's gonna have a freddy skin
for it eventually so
wow you're going to have to share it
we're going to have to react to that
damn eric live when it's moving
so i hope you enjoyed this video you
creative
freaky girl you why'd i say it like that
i'm sorry i don't know
i don't know if we turned the lights out
and then maybe
did it with a flashlight then it would
make sense and it would be like you know
yeah with that freddie after that i'm
canceled hey you are cans because i
said it a weird way oh yeah well it's
too late now though you already said it
so now we just got to kind of get your
comeback
going you're right yeah when is when is
it enough when how soon is too soon i
gotta start on a roll
that mirrors the guilt and regret
of that moment of a mistake i made on
something i said and
that way people will respect me again
you can get mel gibson directed ooh
perfect survived copenhagen
you